Washington journal continues Elizabeth
Warren is at our table she is the chair
of the Congressional tarp oversight
panel and they have asked Secretary of
Treasury Secretary Tim Geithner to
appear before them today on the tarp
program your report came out at just an
anticipation of this hearing the
headlines on the report on your study of
tarps effectiveness are what well that
there's good news and there's bad news
the good news and it's very good is that
tarp in conjunction with other strong
federal actions actually from the Fed
action from the FDIC the stimulus kept
this economy from plunging over the
cliff into what would likely have been a
depression and that's that's a powerful
impact the bad news is that that was not
the only purpose of tarp tarp wasn't
there just to save a handful of large
financial institutions if you read the
statute it's very clear that Congress
intended that tarp was going to get
ahead of the mortgage foreclosure crisis
that it was going to restart lending
particularly to small businesses which
would have an impact on employment and
it was going to be used to clean up the
balance sheets of the bank's didn't
happen didn't happen didn't happen I
want to get to calls pretty quickly for
Elizabeth Warren I know many of you have
questions so we'll put the phone numbers
on the screen 202 737 triple zero one
four Republicans 202 737 triple zero to
four Democrats and our line for
independence 2026 280 205 Twitter and
email also ways to get to us yet this
week the Treasury secretary announced
the extension of tarp has the Oversight
Panel taken a position on that well
remember whether or not to extend tarp
by statute is solely within the
discretion of the secretary of the
Treasury what's more interesting and
very much links up to the report we just
issued is that he says that the reason
he is extending tart is so that he can
now focus on small business lending how
mortgage foreclosures not talking so
much about the balance sheets of the
banks so you know there's there's
clearly a tie-in and if that's how tarp
refocuses itself then I think there'd be
some support for the
on the panel when listening to some of
the analysis on the mortgage crisis the
second wave we hear people say is going
to be exacerbated by job losses what
really is the key to unraveling the
mortgage situation and that the the
situation the country finds itself in
well you know part of the key i think is
to admit that the programs we have are
not working we've basically known about
this crisis you know this is this is not
like we woke up one morning and said oh
my gosh there's a mortgage foreclosure
crisis there are some folks I was
certainly one of them who were pounding
on this years and years ago but even two
years ago we could tell that the numbers
were jumping we could see that there was
going to be a problem and basically
we've taken the approach of asking the
mortgage investors pretty please would
you help deal with this crisis by
working with your borrowers and the
mortgage lenders many of them said sure
and the way they worked with the
borrowers is they increase their
payments and up the penalty fees so you
know the program hasn't worked so we we
started under tarp now with what's
really the third foreclosure program
this one has problems because the scope
is too narrow the scale up is way too
slow and too small and ultimately it's
not going to put homeowners enough
homeowners into permanent solutions in
other words we're deeply concerned that
this program is just kicking the can on
down the road and and I want pause for a
minute to say that is a real problem no
one focuses on just delaying
foreclosures means we're creating an
economy that would have an elevated
number foreclosures and I don't mean by
a little bit i mean by a lot for years
and that has powerful implications in
the construction industry directly but
often things like furniture buying
industry and in you know home
improvement stores there's a real
economic impact to having all these
foreclosures and the downward pressure
it exerts on unreal estate prices with
the extension of tarp the oversight
annals duties are also extended we're
going to put on the screen the members
of the congressional tarp oversight
panel as we take our first telephone
call for its chair Elizabeth Warren
Warren it is from El Paso Texas this is
David on our Democrats line good morning
David good morning I was wondering
what's the problem with just paying down
the deficit with the money that's being
paid back into art look David there's no
problem with that any money not spent in
tarp will necessarily make the deficit
smaller or be available to spend
somewhere else but we all this is about
is that seven hundred billion dollars
was allocated to tarp and the Secretary
of Treasury says he at this point
doesn't anticipate that he will use all
of it that means the deficit will be
reduced and if he uses even less it will
be reduced even more we have some of
those numbers we're going to put those
on the screen please about the 700
billion and how much has been committed
and what the estimated repayments are as
we look for that those numbers let's
listen to a comment from Buford South
Carolina this is chris on the Republican
line good morning Chris you're on the
air for listen for good my question was
Mother's warned you you've been you've
mentioned that you aren't very happy
with some of the usage of the tarp by
some of the bigger banks and I was
wondering how you felt about them I
guess using some of those funds to uh to
underwrite some deals to pay back the
tarp money you know so the big concern
I've had with the money that we put into
the large financial institutions is that
we shoveled literally hundreds of
billions of dollars into those financial
institutions on basically a
no-questions-asked basis secretary
Paulson a year ago told us oh they'll
start lending again that will get the
economy revived there'll be money
available for small businesses we're
going to use remember he said originally
we're going to use the the tarp money to
solve the foreclosure crisis none of
that happened instead we just gave the
money to the banks and the banks you
know
we're not quite sure how they used it we
believe some of the financial
institutions used it in order to just
plump up their balance sheets in other
words they held on to the money and
didn't lend it others used it to buy
other banks increasing the concentration
in the industry others used it to buy
specific assets including assets in
foreign countries now the banks are on
more solid footing or at least so they
claim they are not making big earnings
from lending which I always thought was
the business of banks instead they
muscle you're making big earnings either
from raising interest rates on consumer
loans particularly in the credit card
area or from getting out in trading
they're actually trading and making
profits right now on the trades and
saying okay we've gotten enough money
from that we're going to pay tarp back
and get out from underneath any
restrictions on executive compensation
and basically want to take the position
you know party on like it's 2005 we
started our program by with the wall
street journal story on ken feinberg so
a recommendation to cap fun of banks
receiving bailout funds at salaries
levels of five hundred thousand dollars
a year are you also overseeing his
recommendations visa V how they affect
tarp oh I hope that this will be an area
we will go in to more deeply this is a
bipartisan panel and I have raised the
issue and and there's another panelist
who has raised this issue multiple times
not all of our panelists have wanted to
talk about executive compensation issues
so there's been a little back-and-forth
tug on that for Elizabeth Warren next
question is from Cleveland and Cleveland
is Maxwell independent line you're on
yes ma'am the money originally was
targeted for toxic assets if i'm not
mistaken and what I'd like to know is
how long do you think it's going to be
before the American people the hundreds
and million zone that are out of jobs
now are going to storm the Congress and
the Senate and do something about these
people that are no longer representing
us in any way shape or
form they are simply taking money out of
our pockets and lining there's along
with the lobbyists that push all this
stuff through it's ridiculous one of the
American people going to wake up and use
the Constitution that little section in
there that says we are allowed to clean
house well we certainly I think could
describe tarp as a bait and switch
secretary Paulson came to the American
people came to Congress and said in
effect the economy's on fire we got to
do something really fast and they said
what and he said we're going to use this
money you give us to buy toxic assets
and the ink was barely dry on the
statute before he said oops that's not
how we're going to use the money we're
going to use the money by giving it
directly to the large financial
institutions that's a that's a pretty
stunning turn and I think that's at
least in part why people have been angry
about this from the beginning the money
was used very efficiently to bail out
large financial institutions but the
payoff and the rest of the economy
simply hasn't materialized and your your
report suggests that what is in fact has
done is create larger institutions who
are now taking on larger amounts of risk
because they know the government will
back them so isn't that the irony that I
a year ago we said here's the problem
the problem is too much concentration in
the banking industry a few institutions
that cause systemic risk or are too big
to fail they would bring us all down and
too much trash toxic we call them assets
on the books of the banks all right
let's roll the clock forward it's now
been 14 months and where do we stand
there is more concentration in the
banking industry than there was a year
ago we've bought up the big banks have
bought up more little banks and more
little banks have failed we have not
cleaned the toxic assets off the books
of the bank so they're still holding a
lot of that trash making it very
difficult to figure out the truth
financial standing for these financial
institutions
and the guarantee the the
too-big-to-fail we now have worked
ourselves into a position where we
rushed in we gave them money now they've
paid the money back but the guarantee
continues to linger so that investors
are now saying hmm so well let me
understand if I invest in bank of
america or goldman sachs um if they win
if they take my money and go to Las
Vegas and bet it on black 22 oh I'll be
rich and if they lose if they make a
really terrible bad and it doesn't work
then I don't have to worry because the
taxpayer will be called on to bail us
out and you know this isn't just
hypothetically speaking the rating
agencies themselves have talked about
the difference in how they rate the big
companies based on with guaranteed city
has an a without guarantees it's a
triple B rating basically it junk that's
a guarantee that taxpayers are providing
and yet these large financial
institutions are not paying a nickel for
it this makes them riskier makes the
whole economy riskier is there a word
for your emotions mood watching all of
this yeah um I am I think i alternate
between furious and astounded um I
really I am stunned by this and I'll
tell you something else that stuns me a
year a little over a year ago the
financial institutions let's face it
they were insolvent they were they were
crashing over the edge they turned to
the American taxpayer we did something
we have never done before not at that
level not with those kinds of numbers
and we bailed them out and right now
right here on in Washington those same
financial institutions are spending huge
amounts of lobbying dollars
to hit the senators and congressmen and
Congresswomen every single day because
they still want to be the ones who are
writing the rules the big financial
institutions they want the status quo
they don't want changes that would cause
them to have to alter their business
plan they like a business plan in which
they keep all the profits and the
taxpayers pick up all the losses before
our next call the another message since
you've taken this job every time I've
heard you speak you have been critical
of the level of transparency why is it
that the year plus into this that the
government can't tell Americans
effectively how their money's being
spent alright so first I want to be fair
because you have to be fair when we
started with secretary Paulson 14 months
ago I couldn't get him to answer the
phone uh we couldn't get him to appear
in front of us and at a hearing we
couldn't get any explanation of what was
going on uh I I really was I feel like
somebody on the outside you know
pounding on doors that were locked and
nobody was listening then we kind of hit
his second phase and that was the new
administration came in and they said we
want to help but it was hard to find
anyone there was a lot of chaos not very
many people but a little bit of
information began to trickle out we're
now in a third phase and there is more
information and so I have a website
there's a website there are things you
can see we have clearer information
flows but still not enough information
yet the Treasury and and the Federal
Reserve really seem to believe they can
operate behind closed doors and you know
maybe they can do that in good times no
one asked before but they have a long
history of operating largely in secret
but these are not ordinary times when
they turn to the American people and say
give us seven hundred billion dollars of
your money to spend however we want to
spend it um to get that kind of
discretion means they have to be willing
to be completely open about how they're
spending the money Buford South Carolina
Ernest here on the air the line huh
there
kristen suzanne to the young lady oh all
i wanted to say is this here in that
thar farm you allocated some a bunch of
money to another country to battle the
people up now i know that y'all are very
brilliant the government is me and the
people so when y'all use that word
government mr. people the people need to
take care of Senate and the Congress
2010 we will but at the same time are
you gave two hundred fifty dollars to a
Social Security why couldn't you give
the people the government which is
people are subtracting both the
billionaire's you got multi millionaires
you got the mean as you got no making
over 350,000 you coulda gave all the
people like you given in Afghanistan and
Iraq and although 30 billion dollars or
40 billion miles instead of lost and I
would not vote for President Obama
because President Bush was smart he
waited three months before he got ready
to get our office an order to bail his
boys on Ernest thanks it's a question of
priorities and government spending that
he's raising yeah and and i have to say
earnest i hear your point I but you know
the right place to go and that is to
Congress on that one it's Congress that
created tarp and I want to be clear
Congress that created at least in this
case an oversight for tarp so there's
someone here to talk to you today about
it and it's congress that setting the
priorities here for how spending will be
done you know the president comes in and
he certainly makes his proposals to but
ultimately it's going to be up to the
voters whether or not this is okay with
him Johnson's this message about
transparency says about transparent tarp
outlays only for the strong of heart I
couldn't take the viewing next telephone
call for Elizabeth Warren is green bay
wisconsin and this is travis republican
line yeah i guess mainly my comment is
that the free market system that we have
in this country really if just left
alone
would regulate itself I don't believe
that recessions and depressions are
created by the free market system I
believe they're created by
over-regulation from the government and
government sticking its fingers where it
really doesn't belong the the banking
industry and particularly the mortgage
problem that we have in this country
wouldn't be there if the government had
enforced banks to loan money to people
by way of mortgages that they couldn't
pay back in one respect or another and
so now what we have is we have the banks
with a whole lot of toxic assets under
books that basically because of the deal
that was made between the government and
these banks I mean what are the banks
supposed to do how they supposed to be
bailed out they have to be bailed out by
the government the government made them
give these loans out the first place
unfortunately they did that with our
money the problem in this country social
issues on financial issues regarding
that the business of the United States
of America is being mismanaged by
Congress mismanaged by our presidents
and their administration and it's about
time that the people in this country
stand up because if the general
consensus and we took referendum votes
on a lot of these policies you people
the decisions that you've made in the
past and the decisions that would have
been made by the American people would
be quite different and we would be in
quite different situation at this point
in time each other sufficient so Travis
I want to agree with you on one point
and disagree on a different one and that
is on this crisis this particular crisis
did start one bad mortgage at a time
that's that's where the whole game began
and that's what inflated the housing
bubble and that's what ultimately turned
into these toxic assets that put the
bank's at risk that caused does 14
months ago to rush in and start bailing
out the banks boy we are in the same
place on that the place where I'm going
to disagree with you though is that when
you look at the numbers on
subprime mortgages started now I'm the
government the government certainly
involved in trying to promote some
low-income lending but not the mortgages
that turned into the subprimes in fact
let me give you what the statistics show
I've just gone through the numbers on
this to try to understand it better what
the statistics show is that the real
first wave of subprime mortgages was
selling mortgages to people who already
owned their homes that is subprime
started as refinancing largely older
Americans who built up a lot of equity
and these folks would come sometimes
even door to door because they were so
profitable and talk people into giving
up the last few years on their 30-year
fixed mortgage into what they promised
was going to be a lower monthly payment
you know of course once you read the
fine print it turned out that there were
huge fees associated with this and the
lower monthly payment only lasted for 24
months the first wave of these were
simply tricks and traps the government
part of this can be measured at
somewhere between about two and four
percent this is an industry that figured
out how to cheat people plain and simple
and the consequence of that was to
inflate a huge budget bubble now there
were also a lot of people who jumped in
and said hey you know home flipping I
can figure that out but mix deeply in
this are a lot of people who got cheated
and my view is that's what regulation is
designed to do it's designed to say you
gotta write contracts so people can read
them and so they can make comparisons no
hiding stuff back in the fine print no
tricks and traps that's the kind of
government support to let markets work
that I believe in a viewer named AI
asked by Twitter if the bigger banks
fail what happens and why would it be
worse than now well I think that's the
right question you know we don't want to
have big banks fail in a way that that
you know causes everybody to to set
their hair on fire it has to be done in
a controlled way that is you make the
announcement you say we're going to sell
off the parts that are
valuable and we're going to have to
liquidate the parts that aren't oh but
it happens you know my background is
bankruptcy I teach I'm a teacher I teach
contract law and I teach bankruptcy law
kind of the Alpha and Omega of the
economic system bankruptcy works in and
we need bankruptcy a an economic system
a free market without bankruptcy is like
you know Christianity without hell there
has to be some discipline on the other
side so my own view on this may not be
shared by everybody on my panel but we
could let large financial institutions
be liquidated in fact in some
circumstances that's exactly what we
should permit to happen until we can
credibly say to big financial
institutions if you make bad decisions
you will pay for it you will be
responsible you can lose your business
your shareholders will be wiped out your
top management will be fired your debt
will take a haircut until that day comes
we live in a world in which the biggest
guys have implicit guarantees and only
the rest of us can fail just a few more
minutes left with Elizabeth Warren she's
going to Capitol Hill for a 10 a.m.
eastern time hearing with the Treasury
secretary most important question you
want to ask him is oh that's a tough one
I have so many questions I want to ask
him i'm only gonna have him for two
hours and of course i have to share with
four other panelists uh I actually want
to start with exactly where you started
he's decided to extend tarp he's
announced that he's going to go in a new
direction I want to know why we believe
that now uh you know he says for example
that he wants to to go with small
business lending look I went back and
check through the documents they've
already announced three different
initiatives on small business lending
where you know how many times do we go
through this yeah where is it so I want
to ask about that I want to ask about
AIG I want to ask about this systemic
risk the notion that the big boys don't
fail and the rest of us do I got so much
I want to ask Minneapolis what would you
like to ask Elizabeth Warren you're on
good morning morning
my questions about the Federal Reserve
and the national debt and I was just
wondering how can the national debt ever
be completely paid off when every dollar
is loaned with interest where does the
money come from to pay the interest well
ultimately you know we pay our taxes and
there are other sources of revenue for
the government uh and so remember you
know I know this sounds hard but it was
back in the early 1990s when we actually
had some fiscal responsibility and we
were running surpluses the government
was net positive would have been nice if
we put some of that money away for a
rainy day we started moving into
changing the tax structure expenses went
up as you know in the 2000s we got
involved in a very expensive war and now
we're in deeper and deeper trouble
Memphis estelle good morning to you and
you're on our Democrats line good
morning I am so excited to hear
Elizabeth Warren this morning first of
all I have a very quick comment for the
sake of time I do have a special problem
because I was a mortgage broker also too
I have maybe a quick solution at
composite to help now I am so happy to
hear her say that the investor caused a
lot of this a lot of people talk about
subprime and people who couldn't afford
mortgages well you went through
underwriting and that's not a bigger
problem with what people think more so
than all these investors you could turn
on the TV everybody we're talking about
get-rich-quick schemes with these
mortgages that's a big part of the
problem those are the people that
couldn't ran on a lot of those houses
secondly I have an odd oh right now it's
having issues without hold bank hsbc
will tell you we didn't take tarp money
so we don't have to help you even though
they bought toxic loans and she was a
person who wonder pets do but she had
this below note she tried to refi she
eventually had to file bankruptcy
right now she's asking to be modified
because of the HAMP program and other
things that you know what created they
won't work with their people lawyers
can't get them to work we're now working
with steve cohen's office a local
representative to try and for something
to happen so that she can possibly get
this hair program or at least give some
sort of assistance and it's like pulling
teeth estelle have to jump in because we
really are out of time with Elizabeth
Warren but that situation is not
uncommon so I wish it were uncommon I
have to say two million American
families have already lost their homes
in this crisis we're projecting out
another six to 11 million families who
may lose their homes and by and large
the mortgage lenders have behaved
abominably here they stand on the
sidelines and I think they're waiting
for their own version of another
government bailout here this cannot be
right they made a lot of bad decisions
and they should be at least the first
ones to pay for those decisions are not
the American taxpayer last question
hallo New Jersey Lorraine short question
please oh thank you it's my first time
calling I I want to know why there's
such passivity and in getting these guys
convicted why isn't someone in jail you
know I mean I will just say you preach
to the choir here I am old enough to
have lived through the savings and loan
crisis when we also had a big housing
bubble and when it brought down a lot of
financial institutions only when it
happened that time what happened was the
investors in those institutions were
wiped out the management all lost their
jobs no depositor ever lost a nickel
that's what the deposit insurance is
about but a lot of people got prosecuted
I'm just amazed that we have gone
through a crisis that is much larger
this time and no one even seems to be
asking those questions everybody kept
their jobs bonuses are back up and
I'm not hearing about those kinds of
Investigations Elizabeth Warren needs to
get to Capitol Hill to conduct her
hearing but thank you for being here and
we hope you'll make us a regular stop as
you continue your job thank you thanks
for talking to our viewers we are going
to spend our last half hour talking with
you about to President Obama's